on this week's show should I leave my
job to invest in property in the news a
new property investment TV show where
contestants are battling out 20,000
pounds is coming soon hashtag V eviction
and we'll be answering all your property
related questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends
hi I'm Russell leads I'm Alistair
Cunningham and welcome to this week's
property investors podcast a good show
this week I'm looking forward to it
Scott yeah it's good good
hopefully the sounds gonna be good I'm
sure it will be so it will be hopefully
well to hear us none of that makes not
for a very entertaining show no offense
Nick so should we tell them the two most
important things that the need for
property investing the two most
important no that's not that's not even
good go and then go go go so number one
is a number two that's all you need to
know if you get that yeah seriously guys
apologies for the sound last few weeks a
technical issue and it's been sorted so
all's good in the hood in the hood in
your sweep it up two months or obviously
this week upbeat I've been filming yeah
lots lots yeah a lot so you know we'll
talk about that later but just doing a
lot of filming which has been fun so on
this week's show should I leave my job
to invest in property this is actually a
question though I know I know I guess
I'm sure you do get asked quite a lot
should I quit my job this is my
situation and what what should I do
one word answer again and I'll answer as
well there you go one word answer mm-hmm
it's such a hard question to answer but
should I quit my job to invest in
property Alasdair Cunningham yes okay
okay
Russell Leeds if someone asked me that
and I knew nothing else you said one
word come on that's not one one one word
answer no why
why yeah well because obviously this is
a bit more complex but I would always
say start investing in property while
why quit your job to invest in property
when it's something that you can do
parts I mean the whole beauty of
property investing is used to create
only you have to put a bit of working
but I think you should be able to do it
while you're in your job without just
stripping away all your security and
everything and just I mean I admire
people that take the plunge and just cut
everything away and I might even do that
but I don't that every advise that I
think it it's down to the individual
massively massively for you before you
start you know just too far down so it's
fun anything tell me why you why you
think they should because when you focus
entirely on one thing you get results
quickly see that is a fair argument and
you get results ridiculous the problem
the problem most people have is they're
trying to do a job they're trying to run
the social life they're trying to do
this they're trying to take the kids to
school whatever they're trying they're
doing so much and then properties a
little thing in the in the top that then
when they get time they'll do it I think
that if you're committed to doing
property and you're committed to making
it work and if the jobs two things
holding you back you've got to make a
decision that says do you know what this
is what I want to do I'm prepared to do
whatever it takes to get there and I'm
gonna if it means I've got leave my job
I've got to leave my job I don't know I
left I I left a business because I was
miserable at that business it was not
getting me it was not getting me
anywhere it was holding me back
now you know what to get into property
so I literally I I gave up a business
overnight I gave up a business tunnel
were best part 400 grand a year
overnight just because I knew is not
what I wanted to do and I knew probably
was what I wanted to do and I was
prepared to do whatever to get into what
I wanted to do and it meant giving up my
business giving up my job and then so be
it
you've got any exact rifice is in life
if you want to get anywhere you do it's
one of its what it's a tricky one let's
week should we go through the pros and
cons
yeah okay so let's look at it first from
your point of view I suppose it does
depend there are questions you've got to
ask go for example
we talked about this before your best
case worst case likely case which which
I recommend doing before you make any
any decision whatever it is but let's
say if you leave your job the best case
is that you'll make money a property and
you'll go on to do something that you
love
yeah but the worst case is that you will
starve because you live in a country
where you know you haven't got benefits
and all you're in a situation and you
literally your whole life will ruin and
you'll die yeah then you're gonna have
to say that I recommend not leaving your
job would you agree with that yeah yeah
so it depend it comes down to the person
just the person boss or the situation I
never think to bear in mind is do you
enjoy your job so if you don't mind
doing your job you know could you maybe
cut the hours down on your job there's
pros and cons for everything okay to say
yes everyone should just quit the job to
pursue probably is a bit of a sweeping
generalization it's not exactly 100%
true what I mean by that is if you know
you're going to do property and you've
got the mindset that you're going to
succeed and you've got everything in
place to succeed in the sense of that
you're not going to starve and you're
not going to have you be homeless and
your family's not going to ministry then
you quit your job if you're in a
situation where you you live in week to
week in month to month and you barely
have you're barely making ends meet at
the minute then no it's not of course
it's not mmm
but it's got to come down to the person
if you're a business entrepreneurial
type person then it doesn't matter what
it's take me take me right so I quit my
job
tell us your story what was going
through your head what happened right I
was in a situation where I had a
business for years and it wasn't it was
going it was flying it was doing
phenomenally well I was doing turnover
400 grand a year
I was probably ranked topped when he
talked there in you in there Europe for
the sales for this company it was a
franchise so I was doing really well it
made me miserable I hated it I hate it I
hate it going to work
III I literally I've never been in a
situation in my life where I've I've
found an excuse not to go to work but I
was finding excuses day to day not to go
to work I was literally just you know
like twisted a nail like I pushed a nail
back
just have a day off seriously like it
was snowing one day and I thought after
the ice the window I stopped a day off
and I'd lo in no drive to get me to work
it's not what what to do mmm and that's
never be I've never been that night I've
always been a hard worker and I
literally January 2017 mean Lisa was our
kitchen table and I said I'm done with
this about enough I've done done had
enough and I phoned up the the line
manager I used to deal with and I said
Lee I'm leaving there's my three months
notice in in the March that year that's
it done
I want a business yeah and I had that
listen I might add a little bit money in
the bank but I didn't have Lords right I
went from being incredibly busy for 16
17 years from when I left school to
literally have a nothing I didn't have a
massive that I didn't have underground
in a bank and looking back was that the
right decision it was the best decision
I made my wife everyone the best every
decision I made in my life because I I
decided what I was doing was not what I
wanted to do hmm and you got to you got
to get uncomfortable do you know I mean
it was uncomfortable for me not having a
job not having a business so I'm at a
position where I've got our family to
support I've got children
I've got animals I've got a house I've
got cars I've got liabilities yeah but I
didn't have an income so yeah many
people would be like you're crazy what
you're doing but I have I had such a
drive to do well in life I've got that
do you think I'm going to starve do you
think I'm going to be in a position
where start looking at yeah it's gonna
take a while right anyway
but do you think I'm in a position that
seriously do you think that let's just
there's just no I don't know let me take
properly let's just say that I lose
everything I've got tomorrow do you
think I'm gonna be homeless next week do
you I'm gonna start next week no because
I'm the sort of person no matter what
happens I will make it work if you're
the sort of person that no matter what
happens to you you will make it work
then quit your job if you're the sort of
person that's a victim and that you you
want you rely on other people to give
you stuff all the time
then don't quit your job because you're
not going to do very well if you are a
driven person you're going to do for
normally well
but you've got to take control of things
you've got to see do you know what I
don't like this job this is not what I'm
gonna do I'm out of here
follow your dream obviously you've been
on the crash course oh yeah you know you
had a plan of what you wanted to do I
suppose that's the or not when I quit my
job I didn't you just quit no I did no I
did not have a plan name you just wanted
to hide oh no I knew that I did not want
to do what I was doing it was burning in
there that made me miserable day in day
out that I did not want to do what I was
doing I hated it I did not want to I I
know people have done that job for 40
years and they're like waiting to just
retire yeah and it's just like what a
sad life that they worked all that time
to but for what so I literally just
promise you Jack McGaw been a jack ten I
can't believe that day it's January 2017
fold up Lee said Lee word I'm not doing
this anymore handed the notes in left
three months later I didn't have a plan
all I knew is my plan was I wanted to do
property yeah a problem I had is I
didn't have money for a deposit I didn't
have all this I didn't have loads of
money kicking about at 15 grand kicking
about it's not enough to buy a house but
look at me now do you not I mean yeah
when you step out and do stuff yeah
amazing things happen but you've got
you've got to truth you got to believe
in there you've got to believe that you
can make this work if you can make it
work you'll do whatever you got to do
see I've never never quit my job but
I've never without having something else
already I like I liked how everything
lined up yeah having said that I think
you obviously if you're if you've never
been measured in my job over there so
I've always I've always enjoyed what
I've done but I wasn't a similar
situation in a way when I thought when I
used to back when I was an entertainer
you know I wasn't very making very much
money was about other day 19 Mitsy Anna
used to work as well she worked for my
expenses and combined income meant that
we were still pretty poor yeah and she
absolutely hated work whose name is
let's say similar she was just
absolutely making a miserable I know I
just said to her just quit yeah we'll
sort it we'll figure something out
because I'm just quit I don't care just
you know making you
that unhappy somewhat it will swell sort
will sort it somehow some way so I think
we got the same mindset I've just never
been in a situation like where where
that's where that's ever been issue but
yeah I agree if you apps if your job is
making you miserable what's the point in
the money anyway yeah if you if you're
miserable and unhappy you know I'm so I
suppose a depends on how unhappy you are
in your job be it depends on how driven
you are to make it work
one of the questions I always ask when
people are planning on joining their cap
I only want people join our Academy if I
think they are gonna make it work if
they want it they don't want it there's
no it's not a magic bullet they're not
it's got all the training it's got all
the coaches got it's got everything you
need yeah but you still need to be the
one that does the work and you've got it
Scott to burn it's got to be in there
and it's got to leave you've got a fire
in your bed ask them what the goals are
so I was scale of one to ten how serious
are making this happen and if they don't
say a 10 I'm not do you get many people
soon five no actually no no dear I get a
few people seen like seven or eight yeah
I'm like why you need to want it if you
don't want it you're never gonna piss
hard it's hard work you're gonna face
fear M you're gonna face fears you're
gonna face closed doors you're gonna
have people tell you're an idiot even
now people tell you're stupid mmm
just me you've got to look at it you've
got stare in the eyes and tell machine
that growing period when you because
we're running a property business is a
business or I was talking to Samuel
yesterday about when we both started our
businesses and when they say about how
crazy hours we used to work you know
like 15 hour a day 16 hour days seven
days a week for six months and then
you've got hot and you go away for a
week or something it's like and even
when you're on holiday you're not
switching off now I've I'm going to me
and Lisa and the family are going to go
and hold it and July July August and
she's already told me she's taking my
phone off me she said you're not having
your phone she goes as soon as we get to
the airport I'm having your phone and
you're not getting back to her come back
yeah that's what I thought but it's
because I know why she's doing it
because we don't switch off yeah we're
always working we're always checking
emails were
was getting back to people and and do
you know what's the worst that can
happen you switch off for a week what is
the worst that's gonna happen you get a
lawsuit against June your business goes
bankrupt while your holiday you don't
realize you come back business is gone
life is gone you gotta start again from
scratch power from that bad
realistically can hang and happen and
we've got people in place it can handle
that if it's a lot easier when you grow
a bigger business and you've got staff
yeah it's something when you're doing it
on your own is harder to switch off the
the biggest problem I had in Windows in
the growing phase or if they all my
businesses was I like to hold on to
everything and do it myself and you've
helped me a lot with this and pretty
much because you're lazy you don't do
anything but know you've helped me a lot
with this outsource I don't mean that
but outsourcing and getting our people
to do stuff because I was holding on to
everything thinking no if you want to
job done properly you got do it yourself
that's like the old-school way of doing
thing I hate that saying I know well but
that's how I was so late when I in my
first business when I had to workshop
like I do everything myself so you end
up being there 18 hours a day 20 hours a
day and it's just ridiculous it's fair
enough when there's only you but what's
the point in hiring people if I need a
job for them I had three members of
staff at this point and I was doing most
of the work and I was having to fix
things that they messed up and it was
just a nightmare yeah yeah no no you
mean okay so pros and cons leaving your
job because we kind of sidetracked it in
a way so I would say this is what I
would suggest okay if you're happy with
your job yeah so if you don't have to
get out and if you've got enough time to
work on your property business and plan
your property business in your spare
time do that yeah if you can cut your
hours down and brilliant but but don't I
know I understand what you're saying
about the strip it away yeah and I get
that and I think you probably would grow
it a lot faster if you did that but that
takes balls of steel yeah yeah it's not
for everybody no it really isn't
you've got to have balls of steel now I
like your whole best case worst case
case yeah if you're gonna quit your job
best case worst case like the case if
the best case is you're going to do
phenomenally well and you know you're
gonna make it then go for it if your
worst cases you're gonna lose your home
doing about feed your kids and you're
gonna be bankrupt they don't do it it's
late the cases some some of the best
case and you're gonna start making money
fairly quickly then go for it but only
do this if you've got the mindset and
the the tools and the people around you
to support you and that you've got the
drive to make it was what all the
reasons why the young people often do
well is they've got nothing to lose
sliced into again samuel about that
because obviously he became financially
free at 21 he went into this is 17 and
he was like people would say sure how
did you do how did you have that islam
well I was living at home I didn't what
I've never never Deleuze do you hear
this a lot people getting confused when
Samuel says financially free at 21 and
no he's financially feat 20 21 21
so he's flashy feat 21 but that doesn't
mean he was richer 21 no no that just
means he was covered as a living
expenses nice you just said he lived at
home his mom and dad and by 21 he didn't
okay but he wasn't his financial freedom
figure he didn't have a mortgage he's
not have kids he didn't have do you not
mean he wasn't driving expensive cars he
was just literally me 1500 a month I
don't know what his figure was but it
wasn't I think there's about two grand
well yeah my point being is it's not top
mega money you know it make a make a
money it wasn't resolved people always
say it to me or Samuel was like a
millionaire 21 no he wasn't he was 490
free at 21 it's a big difference between
financially feeling me but the
beautifully work waver honestly free is
it then does free you up to surely focus
it's like having the job that takes up
none of your time yeah exactly so that
we I mean that if you could get a couple
of deals under your belt
well that that's probably what I would
recommend actually I would recommend
doing a bit lil bit part-time get a
couple of deals under your belt so
you've got some sort of income coming in
then a you've proved yourself it works
be you've proved yourself you can do it
and see you're not as vulnerable cuz
I've got some money coming in yeah would
you agree I do agree yeah absolutely
agree do you still I agree I do
agree but I think look if you know
you're gonna do this and you know you're
gonna make it work the jobs just holding
you back but I understand why a lot of
people have to keep that job but
obviously I do because they've got
commitments and for instance let's just
see it look like you're in a supportive
relationship your partner yeah and your
partner's income can cover all you need
it might mean you have to cut back on
luxuries for 1600 well that's a
different kind of fish certainly so they
should see the husband and wife husband
and husband girlfriend girlfriend
whatever at one point I can cover it
just to be PC yeah kind of one partner
can cover the other partner yeah so you
then it's much easier if you're like a
single parent and you've got a couple of
kids in it it's gonna bankrupt you then
it's not for you do it slowly because if
you want to just go all-in
let's just call for this then I think
yeah getting rid of the job is the first
thing I'll do are serious to do and I've
recommended there's still quite a few my
friends and yeah just go for it just go
for it if you're gonna do anything
you've got to do you've got to do a
whole heart the good thing about gotta
make it work yeah course a bit so you if
you want to get your job and you really
want to make it work it leaves your
situation right one of the problems I
see with with people that they try and
do this on the side is it doesn't get
the feel attention they've got the
motivation to give it their attention
yeah but that lasts about a week and
then it dies off because they've still
got the job to rely on when you've got
nothing coming in it brings out an inner
being and you believe me yeah when you
have to earn money because I still
that's the only way you earning money it
brings something and you that you will
not get when you've got the security of
a job I've not been employed since was
22 years old and believe me I've had a
very good life I've had I've never been
to a point where we can't afford to eat
we've had proper we've had times when
it's been hard and we've had not a lot
of money but we've always been able to
eat we've always been always had a roof
over our head because it comes down to
the person and the mindset and if you're
a few of our mindset and a person that's
gonna make this work listen you could
put you could put people like me and
yourself in a completely foreign
place and a time we don't know and we'd
still make money because it's the
mindset in your and you believe you can
still make money hmm and that's why I
believe it will annoy a lot of people
but you know what you kind of want me
over to be honest you've kind of know
wait what the first time ever you've won
you over
are you making some compelling arguments
I'm strolling to argue it yeah so at the
end of the day it's not for everybody
right I'm sure you tell me you don't
agree with me which is your opinion man
is fine they said that my opinion is yes
if you want to do this properly you want
to succeeds quit your job endorphin I'm
very interested to know what the view of
things a if their people have been in
this situation of either quit their job
or not quit their job or be what do you
think should you quit your job as
Alastair right has he persuaded me was
ego threat I'm not sure please do
comment below we're very interested know
what you guys think right it's now time
for this
[Music]
so in the news this week I say in the
news I've been seeing this on the
property investors with Samuel EADS
Facebook group popping up in lots of
different newspapers lots of different
people standing outside this grand
looking castle yeah so let me give an
example of one of them so this was in
the York Express it's property related
news your cancer survivor
Abigail Patterson joins YouTube show the
eviction basically goes on to talk about
a woman who suffer from a brain tumors
and she was childs currently completing
a new TV business competition dubbed the
new apprentice okay so first of all what
is the eviction what what is the show so
in essence it's a an apprentice style TV
show yeah that's 13 contestants are
taking part in and each week they're
gonna be performing a different property
related challenge yep and each week
numerous people are going to be evicted
until there is one winner and one winner
remaining who will win 20,000 pounds
cash Wow
so it's a pretty cool show it's a
similar to The Apprentice in many ways
it's been good fun it's been good isn't
it we're featuring on the show as well
with the judges yeah with the judges we
go around we follow them we criticize
them we tell them what they've done
wrong why they're stupid yeah Alistair's
very Alastair is brutal
he's absolutely I fail into the rule
very easily let's just say that yeah I'm
- I'm too nice and you probably wouldn't
think that what should watching watching
us on the show everyone thinks that I'm
an [ __ ] but actually he's the [ __ ]
I'm actually really nice I find it hard
being nasty to them because they'll try
so hard they work so much effort and
their work in such long day so I'm
pulling him upon the back and get well
done and I hate him good you're rubbish
was that of thin Scottish accent very
good rubbish
but yeah no no no it was good it was
good fun long days long hours it's going
to be our master
massive massive hit yeah it's such a
phenomenal program and the contestants
are they're so deserving and they devote
on really well and adult and like the a
lot of the national media have picked up
on it so like it's not just New York
because they're it's all over the
controls of the I think John Reybold was
in like the Sheffield star and the look
the the Daily Mail Daily Mail yet the
one was in Daily Mail last week they're
everywhere that is popping up so I don't
know how like the the the place to even
go Internet I know we had a few
photographs come down but I didn't think
I didn't think they would go nuts with
it like they have yeah and but it's gone
crazy and it's going to be an absolute
sort of sensation I also think it's been
very interesting from a viewers point of
view to see because all the all the the
candidates should we said have come on
they're all people that have got a
decent knowledge of property yes so the
Royal Academy members yeah they've all
been on the academy less than six months
yeah so relatively fresh yep but they've
got a ground a grounding of knowledge
yeah they've got they've got the
knowledge that they've learnt from the
training and none of them are in a
position where they've got loads of
money they've got a little bit of money
but they've not got lords so when we
were selecting the people for this event
we wanted them to be people that I'd
been on the CAD in less than six months
and they had like a little bit of money
but not lords so that they would really
benefit from winning the money we're you
know 20 grand and we want to see how
they will spend that money and how they
will invest that money yeah it's a
phenomenal phenomenal we don't know what
the filming is still ongoing don't know
what skin it was gonna be happening yet
it's gonna be launching in Nikhil him
with a day May the walk may the 14th
14th of May on on Samuel Leeds is
YouTube channel yeah 7 p.m. Tuesday the
14th of May it's gonna be a five-part
series 24 5 weeks it has been filming
yet like you said has been a blast and
what yeah start again
what about the venue what do you think
the venue the venue's amazing amazin
wanna come on Castle CAV as well it
covers wall covers what I was worth
castle
or castle yeah so we've all just been
living there living there for two weeks
pretty much yeah until people get
evicted they have to go yeah we were in
a nice part of the castle where the
candidates were in the servants quarters
we were in the bit where they forced for
post beds massive rooms Darwinist out
there steps in my bed
has he not with me well obviously a long
time ago but you know is good for
scenery lots of artifacts in sort of
body armor and all sorts kicking about
in there but what I was really
interesting from a viewer point of view
it's gonna be very entertaining mm-hmm
but bill you're gonna see how these
people that are good at property how
they find deals how they negotiate how
they presents how they look for no money
down deals how they how they do and I
think it will be a great not only
entertaining but great learning
experience as well watching it and you
guys go and well I could've done that
like this or I could do that I think it
means my real life isn't it so like me
and you were there just to watch were
just monitor and really we weren't there
to help or assist we were there just to
monitor and just see what they got up to
when Samuel wasn't around so and some of
the tasks were interesting yeah they
were very interesting overall they did
really well but there are some hilarious
hilarious moments on there as well I'm
sure I haven't seen the edits yet but
I'm sure be good good stuff what wait
what we're like something it's gonna be
amazing so I'm really excited about
seeing that I'm really excited about
coming out and I'm sure watch this space
I'm feeling me more news stories coming
and if you want the hashtag for it is
hashtag the eviction so you know please
do check it out on social media please
do comment and we want to create a bit
of a buzz for it is really excited
hopefully you guys can be a part of that
as well because I'm very excited to be
amazing never know we'll be doing it
again next year and looking for yeah if
you want to apply
20,000 pounds cash and learn a lot and
not it's not more importantly you're
around people that are all in property
in all doing like reasonably well and
learning how to do it oh it's crazy it's
a learning experience is phenomenal so
let us know below why you should be part
of next one because it's gonna be
awesome
right it's now time for this
[Music]
okay so on this week's question session
we have loads of questions and then
we're gonna do our best to answer a few
of them now so the first one is from
Rick's risk risen glad your attempt at
the root leaf Rouge on there's few John
I think it's it's our Iza I think that's
like risk risk risk Freudian River risk
gonna be this first question is from mr.
faroush on hey guys I like the show
Thank You Man thanks risk thanks for all
the invaluable input two questions from
me oh you're getting your money's worth
we love your risk okay how do you decide
whether to keep a property or to sell it
ah interesting question cool don't
answer it yeah okay well I'm assuming
that you're talking about light after a
buy refurbished refinance I'm assuming
or do you or do you just mean less you
have Merle a lot of property I keep it
I'll sell it yeah I think maybe in James
client to the buyer but refinance you
answer the other yep all right cool so
when when you do buy refer with your
finance because he's a question that
comes up a lot do I refinance hmm or do
I buy refurbish and sell yes and my
simple answer is I just look at it
objectively would I buy that property
for that price if I saw it on the market
as an investment problem so if the
answer's no then I'll sell it yeah if
the answer is yes then I'll keep it
refinance it so for me what's the return
on investment on that as a property with
those figures yeah so the fact that
you've done a br by reproach friends is
relevant ya know you've got a look at
the standalone property correct would I
buy it and that can I borrow furbished
it do I now sell draw refinance would I
buy it like that that's the question
right what's your answer it's kind of
similar I suppose is it giving you a
good return yeah so if you're using see
for instance they stick from a sourcing
point of view so let's say you've found
it and you decide them well to keep it
yourself or to source it onto our
another investor investor it's if it
matches your criteria then yeah keep it
if you're in a position to buy it then
keep it let's just say for instance it's
outside of your area then sell on and it
all depends what you're looking for if
you
happy with 20% if you're happy with 15%
it doesn't matter but what's your
criteria man and if it matches your
criteria you can afford it and you want
to keep it to keep it if not sailor so a
question - from your your question was
lease option agreement can we have a
step-by-step guide please to start on
lease option agreements you certainly
can get yourself along to property
investors crash course and it could put
a link below and Simon covers in detail
so that's www.investmentpitch.com
we did discuss it yeah and we kind of
went through it went through the steps
so if you go back to the show Nick could
you put a link to that show right now so
you can just click on it if you go back
to that show we talked about at the
beginning of the show for maybe about 20
minutes or so so she'll be able to give
you a I think it's the one where there
was a bit of a sound issue the first
sound does she want ah okay but you'll
miss little tiny bits of it but you
still get the idea so apologies again
for the sound issue but thank you a risk
risk right next one I'm gonna go for
Luke Valhalla hey Luke Aiden but do you
think there will be another financial
crisis or crisis even
Chris's such as the one in 2008 in the
next 30 years yeah probably yeah I'm I I
would imagine do you think it happens a
V every period of time also do you
consider the rates of inflation in your
business plans and if so how ie
service combination rental rent and
other strategies the rate of inflation
well I think is inflation affects
everything doesn't it yeah yeah I you
you might put it in there but it's it's
if you're if at one percent or whatever
it was inflation at the moment one and a
half percent I have no idea but it
should it should affect everything
reasonably equally yeah so I wouldn't
worry no in stress
if 1% or what is gonna [ __ ] your
business good good good point now Luke
okay moving on to barked why take it all
the difficult names bar loom eg buzz
sing ski I'm gonna call you Bart
so hey bar I've actually spoke to you
several times on messenger so good
morning Cancer Foundation be run in the
same property with three bedrooms over
two floors or would it be better for air
being for B&B
yes else combination in houses work very
well yeah I actually think we must be
better for being old on he means be been
a bed-and-breakfast people you can
actually run a bed-and-breakfast as
serviced accommodation yeah so we're
actually buying one at the moment it's
an old B&B 11 bedrooms and we're just
we're just running it as service
accommodation cool Jilly Barlow does
that a lot
well I think service companies from the
works of eight are in houses anyway
he'll be just renting out the rooms
ensuite en suite rooms run as they're
being but yeah as I know air B&B a run
as being me absolute like a but yeah I'm
gonna be there yes it's like being be
with no you be just be okay final
question yeah I'm from Paul Williams
Academy member so hypo hey Russell and
Alistair hey Paul hope you wolf had a
great Easter weekend we did we did did
you
my question is would you recommend would
you recommend it to be okay to purchase
your own property portfolio and or a
deal saw some business or should we keep
it all separate so he's got a deal saw
some business would he buy his own
properties underneath that legal entity
ah okay well no let you answer this but
knows that you'll no no no no two
separate companies simple as I did tell
you this last week a deal sale mastery
no no no listen um I would run your
source in business as a complete
separate entity to anything you put
investment properties in the reason is
protection because it's just worst-case
scenarios say that something goes wrong
with deal selling business do you want
to effect and and there's just hi plate
let's say you've got a nice successful
deals or some business and you've got a
successful property portfolio when we
say hypothetically poll which all that
you do
you know we're not trying to be hard but
ethical is not the work yeah this is
just an example so we're not trying to
say that you don't I'm sure that you
dogs are you're brilliant
carry on you are brilliant Paul and
Catherine right so you've got a
successful deal saw some business which
is making all this money not hugs that
they just you just got it yes we shut up
all right right you've got a property
portfolio let's just see you've got ten
properties and now hugs that way
hypothetically let's say something goes
wrong with company a which is the deal
saw some business and you have and it
shuts down you will then lose all your
properties because the same they're all
under one entity so no you should have
everything separate in my humble opinion
but do speak to an accountant and get
their advice
the alil office advise you legally I
have everything in separate companies
much like Richard Branson everything's
in separate companies so that if one
record shop or one one shop goes under
it doesn't bring him bring down the
whole the whole empire to see we almost
made it through an entire episode about
me dissing your age until you said one
record shop anything I mean you've done
it yourself yeah self like that thank
you very much for tuning in we will be
back next Saturday at 7 p.m.
please do not forget to subscribe let us
know what you thought the show and we
will see you next week see you guys
[Applause]